tu as déjà été voir une voyante non moi
je rêve fait que des super beau rêve qui
se réalise à chaque fois c'est quoi ton
rêve son dernier rêve c'est quoi non
mais je peux pas dire ses développeurs
rêve de ou fait quoi des trucs de la
luxure du péché on va pas le dire on
reconnaît on à lui sur tes rêves et tu
as 10 réalisé à chaque fois ça ferait
alice et tu rêves de quelqu'un ici
parfois copenhague
ouais mon avis allait elle est réelle je
connais les yeux et que tupperware
coller son rêve fait la voix la voix je
suis sûr et certain je suis sur scène
c'est vrai tueur est le benhaim bah oui
j'adore oui mais non mais non mais rien
messieurs je voudrais pas qu'on a fait
plaisir c'est une fille qui m'écrit tout
le temps qui me harcèle pas parce
qu'elle est c'est toujours des mots
gentils mais qui me suis tout le temps
sur tous les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'elle était moine payante qui m'a dit
qu'elle était faite pour moi qu'on
allait se rencontrer et donc amélie
crois je peux pas l'empêcher nationale
et continue écrit pour qu'on se rend
compte en lisant je suis sûr qu'on va
s'aimer mais non ses geôlières montagne
ça va c'est ça la salle a rien à voir je
vous dis bon